hey guys welcome back to big mood we
have a special announcement today we've
been
doing this for a while but you're going
to say special guest
special guest our special guest
i mean at this point i know she's a
special guest today
hello you're a special guest how have
you been uh dude
crazy ask yourself what's your social
media hey guys i'm i'm
at big boss bows on instagram i wore you
know i wore a shirt with uh barely any
clothes on and i'm realizing this now so
all the one-handers please follow me
thank you oh come here
give him a thumbnail she got them big
old titties too
oh hello no i'm just kidding dude i just
opened the door for so many dick pics
i'm sorry
yeah okay i'm sorry nikki what are we
doing oh i was like it's like well we're
matching
i i got but no i got no boobs you have
no titties though so no one cares
not really matching um yeah so a lot of
people have been wanting to know
where did bose go and we've been wanting
to address all of this but
um unfortunately a lot of stuff happened
with the pandemic and
also uh a lot of business stuff frankly
like
behind the scenes stuff that we just
wanted to get settled we didn't realize
how long it took
and we didn't think that it was taking
that long until
everybody was like yo why haven't you
said anything so everybody's
freaked out on us yeah
but you know reasonable we lo a person
that has been in our group
forever uh that was a huge energy to the
show
uh was now missy from the show and so
like obviously
we want to know where she went and so we
have bose here today and we wanted to
make sure that everyone was all together
to
uh to fill you in on everything just so
nothing got
muddy or murky or there's no like
scandals going on or whatever
um so bose and we wouldn't do it in
person but [ __ ] everything's shut
down again
yeah everything was open and then it
shut down again and we're just like
recording
uh another set of episodes and then so
we're gonna be in the studio but then
now we're like are we gonna have to go
back on zoom episodes we don't know it's
a [ __ ] mess guys yeah
yeah this is the way we could give it to
you guys soonest and also like of course
we're
we're smiling we're laughing like things
are good like i we don't want to make
you guys feel like at all like we're not
taking this seriously because like a
core member
just disappearing it is really serious
and we want to talk to you guys
seriously but
also you know we're in good moods i'm
happy to see the girls again we're all
on a call together so
please excuse our light-heartedness
because it's just real like
we're just [ __ ] here but yeah i've
i have i've been moving i've been
working on some stuff
um i don't know if i should say this
right now but
ooh secret yeah give it to us girl you
can bring it up like serious
if you guys remember one of the very the
literally the first episode of
hey [ __ ] there was one thing it was
like boze what do you always want to do
and one thing i've always really wanted
to do is music so
this year i'm drawing an album no
[Applause]
i literally it's so so long story short
i am i'm sorry i'm flying off into the
sunset
i got a new apartment um i've been
posting about it online i have my own
office it's a little echoey there's
nothing in here
i literally hold the wings of the house
i should i should have a wing
you got a wing of the house
so this year i mean to put it completely
completely honestly
um i've always been in groups and i have
always kind of wanted to do my own thing
and when we're together as a group
whether it be smosh or whether it be you
know big mood
there is a message and there's a thing
that we're all putting out together
and i really really really want to do my
own thing like i am the [ __ ] rebel
without a cause
i want to go do my [ __ ] like i just want
to be fully independent which i
haven't been in a very very long time so
you know i'm in this new apartment which
i [ __ ] love we're locked up again so
it's the best place to be right now
i've got my own studio i'm messing with
music i got a producer the other day
that's just like sending me beats and
he's like hey sing on this and i'm like
okay
and you got a cat you got a she's a cat
lady guys
i'm so cast
my roomba too much um
so i was like i need a cat so i fostered
a rescue uh he's
he's asleep right now day two but i mean
yeah i want to start up
new projects that are just completely me
independent i can steer it any direction
i want i don't want to feel like i'm
like ever holding the girls back with my
crazy ideas or some [ __ ]
like i just want to be me dawg there is
a lot of cooks
in this kitchen i mean we we've all
realized that like there was
six of us at one point now than five and
then now four and just like it
we've we can see that bose is so much of
a
like she has so much creativity that
it's just like
you know and she's like so young and
vibrant and [ __ ] crazy and some of us
are like whoa that's a lot of ideas you
know like
like all all the married and like
crochet
[ __ ] yeah yeah where's the child gone
she's run off again
um and like guys honestly that's
[ __ ] raw it's [ __ ] true and it's
real like
it's just yeah and i've i've actually
been like watching over the past few
weeks and seeing some of the episodes
you guys have put out like
just even the harmony that i'm seeing
makes me so [ __ ] happy
um so this is a weird chapter for us
that we're navigating and then
you know there's also like continuing
the friendship after we make some
changes in the business and
personally guys that's something that we
want to work through like
on our own together and we are and
things are going well like
we look we bunch of real ass [ __ ] we
ain't gonna hop on this call and smile
at each other we [ __ ] hate each other
and that's facts
but we are going to tell you guys what's
going on we're figuring things out we're
figuring it out together
but you know as far as business we
wanted to keep you guys posted
yeah i love that and also and yeah in
the beginning um
i know that when when you first wanted
to go do your own thing we were like oh
man like
like there's each person i feel like has
their own mood their
their own big mood their own personality
and i feel like
it speaks i feel like it uh
relates to a different um member of
every audience like there's always like
a different type of person that's going
to relate to each
separate personality and so we've done
so well
yeah and i know like you were saying
that like it seems like we're harmonious
now and
we love it but well there's always going
to be like that piece missing so
at first yeah we were definitely
definitely bummed i mean
not at first we still are bummed um
we're missing a huge energy from the
podcast but also we're like super
[ __ ]
pumped for you dude like i'm so happy
that you're like
living your your uh your dreams like the
from the [ __ ] first episode saying
that you wanted to do music
i mean i'm figuring it out you guys if
you don't [ __ ] hate me for leaving
because the girls did not want me to go
you're gonna if you follow me like on my
social media journey and [ __ ] you're
gonna see me try some new stuff
like you know uh mia khalifa and i are
gonna possibly do
like a mini show on the side one of my
friends just hit me up about doing like
an advice stream on twitch
i'm doing a little bit of stuff with
david i there's no
there's no like pieces that you're
missing there's no nothing your voice
just gonna be out here
like a wildfire just putting her hand on
every stove until i figure it out and
when i figure it out you guys are gonna
know
because when i'm happy i don't shut the
[ __ ] up i got your stuff
everywhere will you come back and be a
special guest sometimes
are you gonna invite me obviously
check your
but there are some things we need to
address
and we're going to dish it out right
here mori style why the [ __ ] did y'all
block my name
okay i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
girl you know why we had to do that that
[ __ ]
was getting kind of crazy it was it was
crazy how fast people
noticed too like how do they know so
fast
and somebody said something about doze
um i feel like this kind of has to come
from me because like i said guys there
are some things
behind the scenes that we've talked
about one-on-one that we appreciate so
many people that have kind of respected
our privacy in it
and i'm gonna be totally honest at first
i think that one of the things that we
could have done better to communicate
amongst each other to provide clarity
for you guys was
if they were like hey bose we're going
to do this and i'm like okay
cool so we missed the communication boat
there but you guys have to understand
we have sponsors we have we have
sponsors that are watching we have
producers that are helping us make
decisions as well yeah
exactly and you know there's there is
we do have to protect the brand and i'm
not sitting here
wanting to watch everything burn like if
they have people in the comments that
are kind of like making a scene they
they should they should control it 110
um i think that we kind of we missed the
communication vote there
we're sorry because i feel like we could
have tightened that up on our end so
that you guys didn't get confused either
because
i posted something too and it was i
don't know but like
i would rather be real with you guys
than just try to sweep it all under the
rug
and honestly i'm [ __ ] cool with it my
name is not
it's not blocked in the comments nobody
we've talked to our producers and
management nobody's
yeah we took that off like like honestly
like we'll comment i don't even comment
anymore but like our producers have
complete control of the channel now so
there's just some things that like
probably don't make sense because you
guys think that we're
acting the same way that we do on
personal channels or even on jk news or
whatever but we have other people that
are
involved in this business too so it's a
little different for this channel
and i'm gonna be really real with you
guys it was mercury retrograde okay
i'm just saying okay like that's
actually what i was going to say too
like
the reason why it we ended up like not
getting that clear communication with
you both is because like we were just
like the production team was like wait
hold on the conversations are getting
redirected from the actual video
you know that it has already been
addressed that we are going to
discuss the reason why bose isn't is no
longer in the videos but then
you know when everyone just like it's
starting
like it went from it went from curiosity
to attacking so then we're like wait
hold on
what do we do right now so that like it
just immediately jumped on the wall
let's just put a band-aid on this really
quick
uh let's block the the name just really
quick let's see like hopefully we could
get together and have this statement
come out asap
and unfortunately it took longer than we
wanted but that's that's really the
reason why it was nothing no malicious
i think we learned from that situation
though like if you just
i mean people just get more angry so you
know
yeah that's a lesson for all of us i i
think it's really really really
important for us to say like we [ __ ]
up and we're sorry
like like there we did and like we're
truly [ __ ] sorry but am i a lot of
curse
yeah like that she's been through a
couple weeks she's asking all but she's
acting all brand new now
yeah well we we started we really did
start a channel where we're
ladies we're reunited you guys have
supported us for so long
and you deserve to know things you
deserve to not get caught up in our mess
when we're figuring it out and you
deserve an apology
yeah like we're real people too like and
i know some of you guys are just so used
to like this youtube tea like watching
all of the
beauty gurus like being really shitty
and throwing things at each other and
being like horrible people we're not
like that but i can see how in your mind
as an audience you can conflate
like that shittiness of people to like
maybe a small show like ours we're
actually real people with real
friendships and we're dealing with real
emotions and like
this isn't some show like some game show
like it's
this is our real life we weren't cast as
entertainers on a show
we were like friends and yeah
real life emotions real life things
happening and so there was some there's
some stuff like that people are talking
about like me and gina
unfollowed bows on instagram it for me
that was a snap
decision that i made because when she
decided that you know she
wasn't really like wanting to stay
because there's so many other
amazing things happening in her life i
got you know like i it hurt my feelings
i was like damn dude like i wish that
you weren't leaving us
and i was upset and like it's really not
that deep though it's like
i just needed a break because our
friendship like needed a break for a
minute and then for people to be like
making a huge conflation out of oh she
unfollowed her it's just like
sometimes you need a little break from a
friendship before
you can go back and fix it it's it's
it's really not that big of a deal guys
i don't know
because like you said it's real people
dealing with real emotions so
that was a real reaction and it was the
same thing for me too like i
it was a snap reaction to me too because
this happened literally when i found out
the news and we were trying like tiff
and i were actively trying to tell bows
like yo we want you to stay let's figure
something out but
you know bose is like i want to fly into
the sunset and i
like you guys know throughout all the
years of me on youtube and everything
when i
have a family my friends i write hard
for them almost to a fault
you know like because i don't really
give a [ __ ] about what happens to me
so i was just like that if it hurt it
was kind of it was like a feeling of
abandonment i suppose i was like oh dude
this is the girl that i've shared
yeah so for that like when she was like
all right well i'm out and i'm just like
bro what so i was very
upset about it and i was hurt and it
felt like why are you abandoning us
after all the hard work that we've
put into this and you know we really
want you to stay but
she you know decided not to so i was
just like all right well
well that's how i deal with things
personally i'm just like you know what
fine yeah because everyone deals with
things differently
so i mean everyone has their they're
entitled to
to react how they want to react and make
decisions how they want to make
decisions
like that's why we're so happy that you
are getting to do what you love
and like yeah like i am so sad that
you're not with us anymore and i've made
it very clear
and like like what gina said like you
know we're trying so hard to get you to
stay but it's
also really selfish i i'll just speak
for myself it's really selfish of me
to to try to like force you or whatever
to be in a situation that you no longer
want to be in and i was only viewing it
from my lens of like
well you're my friend i love you we're
doing this thing together
like like [ __ ] please stay you know
but
now like i i've realized like i'm just
so happy that you get to do what you
want to do and you get to spread your
wings
even though we are no longer in
entangled
in this show together an entanglement
dude
i really appreciate that because like i
will always support every single thing
that all of you guys do
and that you know that's just me on that
[ __ ] like if you happy
i'm happy god my mom is
and i mean you know it is what it is
like i feel like the audience is getting
such a raw
real conversation right now and that's
what the show has always been about
you know yeah i want to like add on to
what tips saying like
i did have that snap reaction where i
was like uh whatever like you want to
leave and just leave fine you know like
i had that raw emotion feeling but then
like now taking a step back after some
time has gone by it's like
i get it like you can do so much more
and like every
minute that you're spending like time is
money and you like you're really trying
to build your career and your future and
like you
you just have to like put things on
certain levels like
there's other opportunities that you
have because you're just
so young it's so amazing so funny so
everything like you have these
opportunities and you need to put those
at the head of this and it's okay like i
i forgive you i get it like i wish that
you would stay with us but i i
understand
why like this is can't be a priority
anymore and it's okay
you know like i get it yeah and i i just
i'm so glad that i just want everyone to
be happy i felt like
i felt like almost like a mom in the
situation where i was like what's the
best for the group
um yeah i get i get both sides where i'm
like yeah like we don't want you to
leave at all
but also i don't want someone to just be
here like going through the motions and
like
you know not having as good of a time as
they could be having in their life
because
i feel like you really thrive when
you're doing something you're super
fully passionate about so yeah it was
like uh okay
you know what what makes everybody happy
and in this situation that was a lot of
what we were trying to figure out behind
the scenes was just like
um you know we don't want to hold anyone
back but also you like
like there's a piece missing you know i
think it's also
fair to say like um there there are a
lot of conversations
that we're still gonna be having guys
like
you know to be completely honest there
are still conversations that we need to
be having with each other
and we're still speaking to you guys
first
you know before we even really sit down
and finish ironing [ __ ] out like
you know because you guys are [ __ ]
forcing us to talk about it before
everything is completely done we
actually
feel like feed the audience something's
better this is actually better because
you get to see a raw view at like what
is actually happening like
like in a friendship with that where a
bunch of friends that own a business
together
and and how that can get like you know
kind of murky when you're going through
your own
like your own personal thing it's hard
bro it's like a friendship and then you
have a business but then you also have
the public eye on you too you can't even
take the time to process everything to
go through all the legal work to go
through all the emotional work
that also comes with this territory like
it does you know we
gave like we gave you guys like the
audience like that
uh entitlement to know like what's
happening
yeah i don't blame you guys but i'm just
saying just this is why it took us a
while because we have to process
everything ourselves
and we also have personal lives like
exactly relationship
issues and all kinds of other stuff well
then there's all this worldly stuff too
like the pandemic and all the stuff
going on in the world like we're all
going through that
as well and then my amazon package is
late like there's a lot going on here
you guys
[ __ ] saying i'm happy that we got to
talk with you guys today
i'm happy that we all got to continue
the conversations with each other
we've all been kind of talking
one-on-one um but it's nice to
have the gang all together again yeah
and maybe
in you know a few weeks or a few months
we do another episode and see where
we're at then because yeah
we can get all the updates on your fun
adventures yeah we'll figure out what's
it what didn't because i'm like bro yo
i'm gonna just say that like my black
ass was like i'm gonna kick up in the
nicest apartment i call this [ __ ] the
palace by the way
it looks like a damn palace
18 foot ceilings in the living room how
many bedrooms do you have a guest room
for us it's it's two bedrooms
two bedrooms but each bedroom like has
his own hall anyways
listen i'm gonna be kicked up at the
palace doing my thing [ __ ]
figuring it out and you know what on top
of that i have to say
it would not be possible without these
girls and this show
because like it gave i was working a
full-time job
this show and you guys gave me the
independence to go off
and live my dreams so i'm sorry this is
it feels like a lot but this is a
chapter and we're gonna make it a long
book
yeah i mean you were with us for a year
like we had a lot of fun we did a lot of
[ __ ] like not everything has to
last forever like sometimes it's just a
season in your life and like we fully
support whatever you're doing i think
it'd be a great episode to figure out
like
you know being a young uh creative in
hollywood like all these different
things you're trying like that would be
a great thing to hear about in the
future
yeah yeah because some of this [ __ ]
ain't worked and i dropped it real fast
like you know
bro i was in ad sales for a minute made
a bunch of money and then i was like
this [ __ ]
sucks yeah like a lot of things that
suck yeah
so but oh but you got you gotta twitch
stream
right i'm going to i want to tell people
like where where can they go now to
like continue to follow you yes okay uh
where you can find me follow me on
instagram
at big wells bellows whenever i have a
new project that i'm trying or a thing
i'm doing or the music
we will i will post that on my stories
um otherwise twitter whatever for
updates but you can find me every monday
at about five or six o'clock pacific
time on twitch
at twitch.tv slash big boss bows we do a
lot of stuff we've
honestly watched family feud for like
hours like my chat and i will literally
watch family feud we watch
documentaries i do a lot of pr
breakdowns um
just stuff like that it'll be really fun
hey shout out to the streamers that
don't have a definitive start time we
just
between these hours we shout out to the
disorganized streamers gina
i got you both you're representing all
right guys
well there you go go follow boze on all
her adventures and then
uh keep following us here if you want
some some candy more candid combos like
this will definitely be rotating
guests and stuff no one's ever going to
take the spot of both did she leave
where'd it go she's like i got a joke
like i've been talking
[Applause]
that was
think that's the perfect way to end it i
was about to say i don't know how to end
things so
she felt perfect hey you know what on to
the episode i'll see you guys later